bienvenue dans PAF pa vous le savez
c'est une émissionù on débat de
l'actualité avec un sommaire extrêmement
chargé on parlera de cet avion
formidable qui s'appelle le sola inPulse
on parlera peut-être du PSG de parinis
qui est déjà entaché par une affaire de
dopage on parlerait aussi des élections
départementales de la polémique sur
Christian tobira du RSI pour les
artisans et les petits patrons enfin
bref il y a beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
à aborder et pour les aborder ben une
équipe totalement paritaire comme dans
les élections départementales avec trois
femmes dont Véronique iturbit bonjour de
versaill plusour voilà le nouveau est
sorti numéro de mars nouveau est sorti
et vous regarderez à l'intérieur il y a
un pur beau gosse je vous laisse prite P
c'est JeanCharles la éditeur et en effet
euh une nouvelle maison versailleuse
voilà avec une photo formidable dans
versaill plus un papier très élogieux
mais juste complètement objectif bonjour
Jean-Charles bonjour Florence mercad
bonjour barreau de versaill donc
Mustapha Larbaoui sans qui le Football
Club de traap et la pharmacie française
ne seraiit pas ceux qu'ils sont entre
autres je pense entre entre autres
Sephora lamanie de l'Université de
Versailles saint-campinatrice et
Jean-Luc madek euh petit commerçant
petit commerçant euh l'homme par qui
l'Ordre des Templiers tient
encore et qui était dans la rue donc
lundi dernier pour manifester 10000 amis
avec 10000 amis pour manifester contre
le RSI on en parlera un petit peu tout à
l'heure euh peut-être on va commencer
par une actualité un peu joyeuse en face
Solar Impulse je voulais juste savoir ce
que vous en pensiez cet avion qui se qui
se meut sans essence et sans pétle r ça
fait rêver je trouve ça formidable ça
fait penser au premierers premières
heures de l'aviation et si ça pouvait
vraiment être utilisé pour des des
avions de transport normaux entre
guillemets parce que là ils sont juste
deux ça serait génial on arrêterait de
bousill les nuages ouais à coup de c'est
merveilleux c'est c'est l'avion le plus
lent du monde c'estàd
que non on a fait le tour de la boucle
c'estàd que normalement l'avion c'est
pour aller vite et là il va mettre
quasiment 3 semaines à faire le tour du
monde
ENF c'est c'est une sorte de nonsens
c'est c'est plus grand qu'un 747 et
qu'un 38 ils sont deux dedans il ils
vont à 3 à
l'heure dit c'est
merveilleux si c'est ça le
progrès bientôt on va faire des voitures
qui vont
reculer est dans la dé je sais pas si
vous AZ une pu formidable pour les
voitures électriques c'est une marque
qui vend des voitures électriques qui
dit on dit qu'on peut peut pas partir en
vacances avec une voiture électrique
c'est faux si vous achetez notre voiture
électrique on vous offre 4 semaines de
location de
voiture et c'est un peu ça exement peu
ça Florence non vous êtes vous ou non
mais je je partage moi oui oui non non
je partage un peu les deux parce que le
progrès ça peut être la lenteur ça c'est
sûr mais c'est vrai que c'est un un
véritable exploit et qu'il y a
énormément de technologie dans ce dans
dans cette dans cet avion et si on peut
utiliser ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir après comment on peut développer
cette technologie pour essayer d'aller
un tout petit peu plus vite franchement
c'était très drôle Jean-Charles
simplement simplement je trouve ça
extraordinaire moi ce qui se passe à
avec ça c'est un vrai événement pour moi
je trouve que c'est vraiment une rupture
de technologie extraordinaire on on
passe sur B voilà un élément de
transport sans sans sans pétrole sans
pollution c'est exceptionnel sans
fr il a raison il a raison il a raison
on a toujours initié progrès en
commençant de la sorte j'ai envie de
participer pour une fois parce que j'y
étais pas la première fois j'y étais pas
la première fois saint exupéri sont des
gens que j'ai appris à connaître par la
suite mais là on participe à une vraie
aventure ça me fait plaisir deouis c'est
bien
bien oui moi je TR ça porte au rêve et
ça porte à l'espoir surtout par rapport
à la pollution parce que l'aéronautique
c'est le moyen de voyager qui est le
plus sûr malgré les accidents mais qui
est aussi le plus polluant et et je
pense qu'effectivement même si
aujourd'hui c'est lent et que c'est à
l'étude pour demain c'est c'est une
révolution je pense que c'est une réelle
révolution ça m'amuse que Sephora qui
étaé au teste de l'air je vois pas très
bien où on aurait embarqué Sephora dans
cet avion elle a d'imagination tu n'en
as pas tu manques d'imagination là
j'arrive pas à imaginer Sephora dans sal
projette-toi ah mais il y a des
entrepreneurs qui se projettent dans le
futur et puis il y a ceux qui écrivent
pratiquement qui écrivent et qui
écrivent c'est un prototype c'est ça
faut le voirat de
prototypeê quelqu'un qui se projette
dans l'avenir écoutez-moi mon avenir et
là c'est il marche à 300 à l'heure donc
je rêve de d'un peu de lenteur ça fait
du bien ouais alors je je signale
d'ailleurs que TV fil est coproducteur
avec notamment la chaîne huayya la télé
canadienne d' d'un film sur C impulse
d'un documentaire et sur aussi le le le
le pilote de solarine puls donc on le
verra prochainement sur sur TVfil 78 ce
qui est une très belle nouvelle est-ce
que vous avez regardé mercredi soir euh
la victoire du PSG enfin la victoire la
qualification du P pour être non ils ont
pas gagné donc vous avez rien dit rien
non Mustapha non footall de Trapp était
là non c'était un vrai un vrai moment
exceptionnel de football il y avait tout
et à la fois voilà l'écriture d'un
scénario qu'on aurait pas imaginé c'est
c'est vraiment voilà pour le coup le
match de foot type pour pour un cas
d'école en tout les cas pour moi un
président c'est vrai que avoir avoir
Zlatan avoir
Zlatan en tant que président bien
évidemment d'une structure modeste et et
encore assez une FL associatif mais
c'est un modèle du genre avoir un match
qui débute avec un leader qui se fait
sortir alors bien évidemment qu'on peut
toujours contester techniquement il y a
rouge techniquement il lève les les
smells il se jette il se projette c'est
dangereux il le prend pour le coup
léralement voilà techniquement il y a
rouge maintenant c'est un peu c'est un
peu abusé et abusif euh il est expulsé
il joue à 10 j'en suis maintenant à me
demander si ça serait pas stratégique
que de commencer à 10 pour tous mes Jes
essayz chez vous alors donc du coup
c'est un cas d'école que je vais
probablement reproduire je crois pas
qu'on l'a déjà inventé ça dans le foot
c'est commencer à 10 et VO rentrer
quelqu'un après alors ça c'est un
premier point un second point c'est vrai
que il y a la main et il y a ce penalty
et là on y croit plus et puis finalement
il y a
ceour c'est retournement de situation
pour pour ma part c'est un vrai pour le
coup un vrai cas d'école savoir que on
peut avoir un arbitrage entre guillemets
défavorable et finir sur le terrain à
gagner il y a un vrai message à faire
passer en toutous les cas moi je
beaucoup il y a à la fois côté moral il
me semble dans cette
qualification ils ont joué à 10 contre
12 enfin parce que l'arbitre était quand
même au-delà de tout ce qu'on pouit
imaginer en c'était il s'est ridiculisé
pour des années en c'est vraiment le
il paraît qu'il part dans le Solar
Impulse refuse on va l'attacher à la
queue de Solar impuls et
puis quelques années non mais c'était
magnifique c'était une dramaturgie
absolument extraordinaire un
suspense en devenir cardiaque et puis ce
qui était très beau à la fin c'était ce
moment de j'ai trouvé un véritable
moment de grâce assez rare dans le dans
dans le sport maintenant où ils avaient
tous l'air contents que ce soit le
président du PSG que soit Laurent Blanc
quelquefis des rapports un
peu milliarda et là on avit vraiment
l'impression j'avais l'impression de
voir mafha gagner une une C impression
parce que clairement j'ai pas les mêmes
moyens c'est vrai qu' ét redeven mais le
côté collectif la j collec et ça le
football le permet le sport en général
mais le footballence vous avez regardé
oui j'ai regardé alors une partie he pas
complètement j'ai
donc c'était une partie de football j'ai
fait une partie d'une partie
j'ai donc raté tous les buts donc j'ai
raté l'intensité dramatique voilà non
arrê à la 80e minute non non j'ai arrêté
quand Zlatan s'est fait sortir j'ai dit
voilà donc ça m'a désespéré j'ai zappé
je suis parti sur autre chose et j'ai
regretté non je connais pas bien non
j'étais sur le papier j'ai pas été bonne
c'est regardé non j'ai pas regardé j'ai
eu forcément des échos mais vousz pas
regardé du tout pardon c'est
pas
voilà flurence a regardé non vous avez
pas regardé parce que vous savez même
pas quelle moi j'ai regardé une dem euh
alors l'actualité la plus tragique
c'était en Argentine avec cette émission
Dropt et et la mort de grand sportif
français
euh ce qui ce qui est est-ce que ce qui
vous a pas frappé c'est que tout de
suite dès que dès qu'il y a dès qu'il y
a un un événement comme ça on on rentre
dans le commentaire et la polémique
c'estàdire la polémique sur Budin qui
est devant les carcasses d'avion enfin
des
hélicoptères c'est c'est très curieux
parce que d'abord ce n'est ce n'est
qu'un fait divhiver c'est un fait
diviver très triste mais le le lendemain
soir il y a un avion qui s'est craché
dans le pas très loin d'ici je crois
enfin je sais pas avec quatre personnes
à bord personne n'a remis en cause le
fait qu'on puisse faire de l'aviation de
tourisme et il y a quatre morts donc
c'est c'est c'est juste la moitié de
quasiment de de ce qui se'est passé en
Argentine ça remet pas en C c'est parce
que des sportifs alors c'est très triste
parce qu'on on les connaissait alors que
les les les les Quates malheureux person
person ne les connaissait mais mais
parle plus d'ailleurs des trois sportifs
que des techiciens VO bon c'est c'est
c'est dommage mais ça devrait rester un
fait Diver et puis c'est tout on remet
pas en question ni la télévision ni TF1
ni quoi que ce soit je dire voilà bon il
sétait il s'amusait beaucoup visiblement
à tourner cette émission bon ok c'est
c'est tragique mais ça ça vaut pas plus
quoi on a l'impression qu'il y a des
morts plus importantes que d'autres à ce
niveaaulà donc voilà ça ça frappe ils
étaent pas en mission pour la France ils
étaient pas en route pour les
olympiqu le vie privéit ridicule c'est
les déclarations de du chef de l'État
enfin Ava Premier ministre chef sont
intervenus le jour même quand même ce
qui est quand même ils en ont fait plus
pour un fait d'iver entre deux
hélicoptères que quand il y a des des
soldats qui envoyé par la France
défendre nos valeurs la démocratie et
cetera là là il y a pas un mot les types
reviennent quasiment maintenant dans
l'anonymat dans une dans une boîte en
sapin tout le monde s'en fout mais là en
revanche 10 10 person
person on en fait un éloge national a
avec des pH pour la
mort pour la l des classes de
Laurence Véronique Véronique bravo pour
cette formule c'est vrai que on a
l'impression qu'il y a des morts plus
importants que d'autres et ça c'est
effectivement important important de de
rappeler vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
nier qu'il y a des morts qui nous
frappent plus que d'autres plus d'autres
là je voula c'est qu'en fait on fait
comme si ces gens-là étaient bon des
anonymes alors qu'en réalité ils sont
rentrés chez nous parce que ça reste des
ça reste des de grands champions on on
les a côtoyé donc c'est une manière de
VO de de encore une fois de faire le
deuil avec la famille parce que ils en
font un peu partie et puis un deuxième
élément c'est que on a maintenant des
chaînes d'infos en boucle et on alimente
donc qu'un moment donné faut l'alimenter
et ces télé on les regarde aussi donc on
est allez on va dire quasi comp tous en
regardant ces télé en regardant ce qu'on
y met dedans et il faut bien aussi
alimenter il est pas choquant qu'on en
parle ce qui est choquant c'est que
François Hollande en face une sorte
d'éloge et une catastrophe nationale
c'est pas une catastrophe nationale
effectivement c'est normal ce sont
quemtionnel réussi aussi voilà ce sont
des champions qu'on connaissait c'est
effectivement très triste et c'est
normal qu'on ça reste un hommage
national à partir du moment où on les a
connu de faç sur le plan national a le
drapeau français pour des médailles
françaises pour dire queeectivement il
représente cette France cette France a
été représenté par eux à un moment
important de leur vie dans leur carrière
c'est juste c'est juste une manière de
rendre Hage ils sont pas mort
représentant la France ils sont pas
morts en combat comme le dit H non ils
sont connus nationalement c'est juste ça
c'est un juste retour parce qu'on a eu
des émotions positives avec eux et là
c'est une manière de communier c'est
juste ça je crois ça va pas plus loin
que ça on en fait toujours trop et
effectivement François Hollande est
devenu le grand spécialiste des éloges
euh bon je pense qu'il faut passer à
d'autres sujets
c'est pas François Hollande c'est le
président à la limite c'est comme
ça en ça faut paser sur le sujet TR le
président le président fait son boulot
parceage à des Français qui ont
compé oui voilà c'est les mors plus
importants d' a techniciens certains que
je connaissais en plus effectivement je
pense que pour les familles ça doit être
assz doulourreux de voir que on parle
que des trois sportifs quand il y en a
SEP autres qui sont décédés de la même
façon après la polémique et la remise en
question de la téléréalité c'est que
pour avoir participé en fait à ce genre
de programme on on on fait confiance à
une structure à laquelle on se remet
pleinement il faudrait savoir s'il y a
eu collision entre les deux hélicoptères
parce que la prise de risque a été trop
importante ou si c'est vraiment un
défaut technique et comme le dit
jean-charge après on peut pas tout
remettre en question l'accident arrive
une fois qu'on saura quelle est la cause
de ce tragique accident euh je pense
qu'on pourra ou non ça a l'air d'être
une erreur de
pilotagef on peut faire une enquête
pendant 2 ans euh peut-être je voudrais
qu'on parle un peu de parinis puisque
parinis a été lancé depuis mon repas et
et il y a est déjà entaché par une
affaire de d'page je propose de voir
déjà le sujet sur sur le prologue de
parinis les cyclistes ont fait le show
sur le bitum de morpa pour ce prologue
du parisce c'est finalement le jeune
champion du monde polonais Michel
katowski de l'équipe belge ethique
quickstep qui s'est imposé ce dimanche
en 7 minutes et 40 secondes sur ce
contre la montre il a devancé pour 31
petit centiè le détenteur du record de
l'UR l'Australien ran Denis l'Allemand
Tony Martin complète le podium on tombe
sur un coureur qui est très à droit
parce que je crois que si mes souvenirs
sont bon il doit venir un petit peu du
cyclocross ou du BTT et sur un parcours
comme ça ça aide énormément il est jeune
donc il a vraiment la volonté de d'aller
chercher une belle victoire et je pense
que il faudra aller le chercher les
Français ont déçu sur ce prologue du
parinis Sylvain chavenel réalise le
meilleur temps en 7 minutes 50 secondes
le deuxè français Tony galopin termine
lui à la 20e place du classement le
prologue rien du tout c'est quelque
chose de très particulier donc on peut
pas tirer des conclusions sur ce genre
d'effort je pense que les premières
conclusions seront attiré justement à la
croix de chour maintenant il leur reste
à attaquer il le reste à les mettre en
difficulté tous ceux qui sont les les
grands leaders de de Paris il y a pas de
raison on peut attaquer de loin malgré
des performances Moré sur ce prologue
tout espoir n'est pas perdu pour les
cyclistes tricolores le français
Jean-Christophe perra 27e à morpa fait
toujours partie des prétendants la
victoire finale la course du soleil
donnera son verdict ce dimanche du côté
de
Nice alors c'est d'abord une très belle
course le parisce je crois qu'on est
très fier d'ailleurs qu'il soit que le
prologue a lieu ici hein ça ça ça attire
beaucoup de monde et puis c'est vrai que
50anttin est une terre de cyclisme avec
on a vu on a vu les championnats du
monde indor c'est voilà c'est là c'est
sur sur sur route euh première première
grande course et première affaire de
dopage ça on on est habitué quoi
maintenant avec le cyclisme ce qui ce
qui est curieux avec ces histoires de
dopage dans le cyclisme c'est que le le
l'UCI enfin et tous les organismes qui
qui gèent un petit peu ces problème de
dopage gère ça mais vraiment de de de
façon très médiatique parce qu'ils ont
les échantillons toujours depuis des
années depuis des mois et c'est tout
d'un coup ça sort juste quand il y a la
course il sortirait pas le truc de mois
avant parce que le type est s'il est
drogué c'est drogué ils le savent depuis
non il attendent toujours qu'il a un
retentissement médiatique donc on a un
peu l'impression d'une organisation
cycliste qui se m la queue et qui a
elle-même envie de se
se de se s'aborder et et puis euh
pe-être des intérêts cela dit peut-être
qu'on oui oui oui mais mais c'est
curieux quand même que que le sport le
plus populaire et le le dernier sport
gratuit le le vélo que tout le monde
peut aller voir gratuitement que ce soit
le Tour de France le parinis on va on
plante sa caravane ou sa petite tente
sur la route nationale on regarde ça
c'est gratuit et cetera c'est le seul
sport qui est aussi attaqué sur le sur
sur le
probablement plus de contrôle que dans
des autres SP alors que sur le rugby sur
le tennis sur le on sait très bien qu'
sont qu'ils sont DEP sur le FO voilà
mais là on dit rien on peut-être ça
c'est pas très grave donc moi je je
m'interroge sur cette cette propontion
de de tout le monde à taper sur ce sport
populaire et gratuit est-ce que c'est
pour dire que de
on pas sûr qu' plus de dopage dans le
cyclisme en tout cas il est plus
contrôlé
probablement c'est une forme
d'hypocrisie d'ailleurs parce que on
voit plus vraiment du sport on voit un
SPECT le sportif et s'il y a pas
justement cette spectacularisation du
sport les gens viendraient plus le voir
comme comme on l'abordait et ça vaut
pour ça vaut pour le cyclisme ça vaut
pour la natation parce que la natation
aussi est plus ou moins touchée comme
pour les autres sports s'il n'allait pas
très vite et s'il n'était pas dans des
performance extraordinaire ça
n'intéresserait pas les spectateur donc
je trouve ça assez hypocrite justement
le oui a une demande probablement et des
spectateurs des télévisions et des
médias à ce que les performances
augmentent ch chaque fois en même temps
même DOP moi je défie
our
oui et puis comme de toute façon ils
sont probablement tous dopés de la même
façon ça change pas grand-chose au
classement si tout je pense
aussi il paraî qu'ils sont pas tous
chargés de la même
façon mais ça non mais c'est ça ce qu'il
faudrait ça serait de contrôler le
dopage de toute façon que chacun voilà
puisse faire des courses avec des bonnes
performances mais en étant chargé de la
bonme façon simplement déplacé la notion
de performance la notion de performance
elle est sportive avant tout et
aujourd'hui bah les scientifiques donc
les performances sont dans le back
office c'est là où on charge c'est un
pharmacien qui nous parle oui vous
connaissez tous les produits pas
forcément un spécialiste du dopage en
l'occurence mais on pourrait parler des
substances utilisées les anabolisants ou
tous les produits qui permettent de
réoxygéner par exemple faire en sorte
que la structure musculaire adapte mieux
s'adapte mieux à l'effort toutes ces
substances existent et il y a une vraie
course scientifique parce que derrière
il y a un intérêt économique alors la
SPECT et on parlait de spectacle tout à
l'heure la télé a les sports
télégéniques par exemple il y a des
sports qu'on connaissait pas hier et
qu'aujourd'hui avec les techniques
modernes de de de de prise de vue ça
devient de plus en plus télégénique donc
on cherche effectivement le spectacle
c'est vrai qu'on voit moin le curling
par exemple par exemple pourtant c'est
l' pourtant c'est bien et il y a un typ
qui balaye devant ce qui est formidable
il cire pas forcément les mêmes
personnes en même temps donc c'est la
téléors pardon pardon non tu dis que les
cyclistes servent de cobail ah c'est par
ce que j'ai dit par j'ai ils servent pas
de cobail en l'occurrence ont fait en
sorte que leur performance soit augmenté
ils sont pas comail c'est juste que
l'équipe au complet c'est plus
simplement un cycliste un entraîneur
c'est maintenant en plus un coach mais
également un médecin un scientifique
enfin mais c'est pas un com pour autant
il fait partie d'une équipe et cette
équipe doit être performante
financièrement je crois que c'est
l'élément l'élément central et pour
qu'il so soit financièrement attraayant
bah il faut des performances et cetera
merci non non mais je je t'en pr passer
un autre sujet qu'on pourrait appeler la
révolte des dentilles ou des considérés
comme comme dentill sont probablement
pas et Jean-Luc nadc va nous le dire il
y aura les médecins qui seront dans la
rue pour protester contre le le tier
Peignon vous-même vous étiez dans la rue
lundi pour des raisons totalement
différentes mais pour des raisons
différentes
mais ce sont des petits artisans ce sont
ce sont des gens qui bossent comme des
fous pour beaucoup qui sont assez peu
exposés aux médias hélas et pourtant ils
sont très nombreux parce que vous savez
que les petites entreprises en France
c'est 80 % du tissu économique c'est pas
rien quand même c'est c'est l'emploi
c'est la source d'empo oui bien entendu
et donc ces gens-là sont à la fois
jamais exposés on en parle très peu et
ils sont très maltraités et là en
l'occurrence avec le régime social des
indépendants ils ont affaire à une
organisation qui les touche directement
dans leurs revenus à la fois pour leur
remboursement pour leur retraite et
cetera et et ils sont furieux parce que
depuis 7 ans maintenant que cet
organisme a été créé et bien les trois
organisations qui se sont regroupés dans
lesi n'ont toujours pas mis leur système
informatique en ordre
les autorités de cette caisse sont
absolument injoignables et un grand
nombre un grand nombre de petits
artisans de petits commerçants ce sont
trouvver en difficulté or il ne vous a
pas échappé que le petit artisan et le
petit commerçant quand il se casse la
figure il a le droit à rien il y a pas
de droit au chômage il y a pas de droit
de protection aucune et donc
inévitablement quand ces gens-là sont
mis par terre souvent à cause d'une
difficulté de remboursement de leur
régime et bien j'aimeis autant vous dire
que c'est un drame personnel familial
terrible et donc ils sont venus et c'est
vraiment très rare de leur part dans la
rue lundi dernier pour exprimer leur
colère et je pense que il faisaient bien
10000 personnes c'est pas rien vous
savez dans ce domaine d'activité où tout
le monde plôt des individualistes bien
sûr mais pas que c'est des mecs qui
bossent beaucoup quo quand vous êtes
menuisiier boulanger patiss c'est pas
des gens qui sont qui sont habitués à
manifester à stirs ils ont pas le temps
ils bossent tous comme des fous donc
honnêtement il est temps qu'ils soit
entendu et il se trouve en plus oui il y
en a évidemment il y en a ça commence
par remettre en ordre la gouvernance du
de ce régime qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement ne l'est pas et bon
c'est un régime qui est sous l'autorité
des commissions paritaires donc salariés
et employeurs aujourd'hui pour les
employeurs donc pour tous ces petits
artisans commerçant qui é dans la rue
lundi c'est l'UPA et la CGAD bah très
honnêtement il nétait d'ailleurs pas
dans la manif fa pour cause parce que
hélas les gouvernances à la fois sur le
plan national et dans les régions pour
le régime social des indépendants n'ont
pas réussi à remettre ce système à jour
il y a qu'à d'ailleurs aller sur
internet sur le site rs.fr pour se
rendre compte à quel point il est élo
éloigner des besoins des petits artisans
et des petits commerçants alors pour
compléter ce que dit Jean-Luc parce que
là tu parlais des problèmes de
remboursement du RSI mais le gros
problème sont des appels de cotisation
qui sont faits par le RSI qui sont sans
aucune commune mesure avec les revenus
des des petits patrons donc il y a des
moi j'ai défend quelques clients
justement contre le RSI avec des
demandes qui de cotisation qui sont
supérieures au revenus qu'ils ont touché
dans l'année donc avec oui ou du chiffre
d'affair al revenu ou chiffre d'affair
donc des trucs complètement dément euh
et où on se heurte à un mur avec
personne pour parler d'abord avant de se
retrouver au tribunal avec des
contestations et cetera et du coup de
l'énergie pour les petits patrons de ce
parce qu'ils doivent se battre devant
des tribunaux de l'énergie dépenser des
frais de justice et cetera où il se
retrouvent même à trait dans le tribunal
de commerce euh en redressement en
liquidation judiciaire par le RSI sur
des sommes qui ne sont pas dues et avec
aussi des prises de privilège et cetera
donc il se retrouve vraiment dans des
situations assez hubuesques et et avec
avec en face personne avec en face çaà
personne SAU aller au tribunal c'est
assz terrible et en plus de ça
normalement les représentants de ces
petits artisan je parlais de l'upéat la
CGAB devrait normalement
CGPME qui ne sont pas venus ils sont
fait huer d'ailleurs ne sont pas venus à
cette manifestation alors que clairement
la totalité de de de nos amis artisans
petits commerçants sont en difficulté
grave par rapport à ce à ce régime
pourquoi on a aussi peu de de
de d'amitié enfin pour justement des
gens qui qu'il faut vivre le tissu
justement probablement je je je parle de
ça souvent dans dans dans cette émission
euh probablement parce que le le le mode
de fonctionnement de la représentation
de ces petits artisans commerçants ne
fonctionne pas bien donc il faut
absolument rectifier le dire parce que
ce que je peux vous assurer c'est que à
la manifestation de lundi 10000 artisans
se sont regroupés qui les a amené à se
regrouper comme ça exclusivement des
collectifs donc absolument pas les
organisations reconnues euh qui ont une
signature vis-à-vis euh de l'État ou des
administrations dans le cadre du
partenariat donc euh ce sont les
collectifs qui aujourd'hui font que les
gens prennent euh conscience de leur
situation et peuvent se regrouper c'est
normalement le rôle des organisations
professionnelles et donc là on est en
train nous chez les petits patrons de se
faire euh finalement représentés par des
collectifs qui mis bout à bout arrivent
à déplacer 10000 personnes ce qui est
considérable mais qui en même temps
alors qu'il faudra aller négocier en
face ne sont pas représentatifs ceux qui
le sont ce sont ceux qui précisément ont
hélas n'ont pas permis de faire des
progrès dans ce régime donc on tourne en
rond il va bien falloir à un moment
donné que nos gouvernants se rendent
compte de la nécessité de remettre à
plat la représentation nationale et
c'est d'autant plus en danger qu'on a
des décisions de justice notamment une
décision du tribunal de grande instance
de Nice qui a été rendu au mois de
décembre qui ne reconnaît pas au RSI la
représentativité sur le plan judiciaire
donc voilà parce que et donc et là en ce
moment il y a des tas d'organismes qui
sont en train de se créer en disant on
va faire concurrence au RSI abandonner
le RS venez chez nous al ce qui pas ce
qui n'est pas encore légal en France
mais il y a des sacrés mouvements qui
bougent ça va bouger ah oui ça va ça va
bouger un mot sur les médecins qui
seront aussi dans la rue pour protester
contre le tir payant est-ce que c'est
une bonne idée à un moment où la
sécurité sociale est quand même en gros
déficite de vouloir généraliser ce tiers
payant ou franchement je trouve ça idiot
moi je trouve que c'est tout à fait
normal qu'on quand on se rend chez le
médecin qu'on a envie de se faire
soigner qu'on ait un acte sans aller
comme quand on va chez un psychiatre à
payer une somme astronomique parce que
ça ferait partie de la la de de la
guérison mais de payer quand on va chez
le médecin ne me paraît absolument pas
choquant et si on paye pas quand on va
le médecin on va y aller de plus en plus
on va y aller dès qu'on a un PAI de
travers dès qu'on a le le le la moindre
névralgie moindre truc hop on y va c'est
gratuit c'est une impression de gratuité
parce que ce que les gens qui sont tous
là comme dVau à dire c'est merveilleux
de pas payer c'est c'est de toute façon
c'est le le le médecin lui finira quand
même par être payé donc c'est c'est une
augmentation des impôts c'est de toute
façon c'est ça mais sur le principe
c'est ridicule cette gratuité qu'on
essaie d'instaurer partout en disant ce
merveieux faites-vous soigner à l'œil
non on se fait pas soigner à l'œil les
études montrent parce que c'est c'est
quand même c'est quand même utilisé dans
25 pays sur 28 dans la Communauté
européenne que euh ça n'augmente pas le
coût de la le coût de la santé oui mais
attendant la spécificité française dans
ce domaine qui va à mon avis faire des
merveilles les acteurs du du du système
tous sans exception sont d'accord sur le
fait qu'effectivement il faut un lien
entre la dépense du soin et et soit
parce que c'est vrai qu' un moment donné
quand tout semble être gratuit bah les
abus arrivent derrière et effectivement
Jean-Charles a totalement raison nous
sommes là dans un système
franco-français ça nexiste nulle part
ailleurs c'est oui le tier payon très
très généralisé ailleurs mais les
systèmes de santé sont pas forcément les
mêmes franchement je peux pas croire une
seconde que les gens vont attendre un
système démonétisé pour aller plus
souvent chez le médecin comme si c'était
finalement ça existe déjà dans les
pharmacie alors justement c'est là où je
voulais en venir mais je vourais
simplement rebondir sur ce qui a été
diton a l'impression que demain parce
que alors d'abord c'est pas gratuit je
crois que les gens le savent que c'est
pas gratuit il payent d'une certaine
manière ça s'appelle des cotisations
sociales donc il y a il y a un enfin il
y a un mode de paiement simplement après
c'est la manière dont ils sont rétribués
alors les médecins d'une part et
effectivement les patients mais je crois
pas que les gens aillent chez le médecin
simplement parce que c'est gratuit on
irait plus souvent s'ils ont besoin ils
y vont et s'ils ont pas besoin ils n'y
vont pas peut-être qu'ils n'y vont pas
souvent alors qu'ils en ont besoin mais
parce que ça nécessite une avance alors
sur ce débat moi je suis quand même
partagé c'est vrai que c'est important
de savoir combien on paye euh un exemple
on a démonétiser également les
médicaments avant il y avait des
vignettes on savait combien ça coûtait
il y a plus de vignettes sur les boîtes
il y a des choses comme ça qu'on
pourrait continuer à à laisser pour
l'information mais je crois pas qu'on
puisse dire que les gens aillent chez le
médecin pharmacien parce que c'est
gratuit et donc on mangerait plus de
médicament parce que c'est gratuit on
irait chercher des soins
c'est dans le pays pardon la vente des
médicaments l'unité comme comme on le
fait dans les pays angxon ça réduirait
pas le coup ça aussi parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours des boîtes qui
traînent avec des Médicam qui serent à
rien je je je veux bien mais simplement
pour finir sur le sujet des des médecins
le vrai sujet en réalité c'est
qu'effectivement ils savent qu'il y a un
précédent c'estàdire que la carte Vitale
nous les pharmaciens on l'a mis en place
il y a à peu près une trentaine d'années
c'est-àdire que maintenant qu' che m le
pharmacien vous apportez votre carte
vital et vous ne voyez pas la dépense
voilà donc c'est juste que la charge de
travail qui correspond au traitement de
la
démonétisation est très forteette char
de travail parce que c'est ça que elle
est éorme c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je prône justement pour un autre
mode d'exercice officinal pour remettre
le pharmacien au comptoir le pharmacien
proche de ses clients le pharmacien pour
apporter un service réel et sérieux
parce qu'en fait le pharmacien
aujourd'hui passe plus de temps en
backofice c'estd dans son bureau à gérer
les flux financiers la mutuelle les SC
faut se faire payer il y a 300 on
parlait du RSI tout à l'heure mais c'est
juste une blague c'est un organisme P je
parle pas de je parle pas du RSI
enurence je dis c'est une blague à
gérer j'aime bien quand il est éneré en
M temps il est passionné en réalité et
donc gérer le RSI mais c'est gérer
toutes les CPM de tous les départements
quand les gens viennent de départements
différents toutes les mutuelles et donc
c'est un vrai boulot énorme de la
gestion des flus sans compter la gestion
des laboratoires pay vou dire des des
flux financiers donc la mutuelle et la
CQ en particulier donc les médecins le
savent et quand un médecin seul dans son
cabinet a traité une population de plus
en plus importante avec le désert
médical ils sont de plus en plus chargés
donc il y a de plus en plus de monde à
attendre depuis qu'on a mis en place le
parcours de soins donc il y a le
parcours de soins d'un côté il y a la
désertification médicale de l'autre il y
a de plus en plus de monde et en même
temps donc il y a de moins en moins de
médecins de plus en plus de monde et en
même temps on voudrait leur donner une
charge supplémentaire parce que ça sera
une charge supplémentaire la seule
charge éventuellement qu'ils auraient
dont ils ont vraiment besoin c'est de
contrôler qu' sont bien payés et on est
obligé de le faire donc voilà il y a un
précédent ça s'appelle la pharmacie au
final les pharmaciens l'ont pris en
disant bah moi je vais le faire parce
que ça sera un service rendu à mes
clients donc ça sera clairement une
concurrence vis-à-vis du voisin sauf
qu'aujourd'hui tous les pharmaciens F et
tous les pharmaciens sont englubés dans
ce système je pense que les médecins ont
compris qu'ils allaient à mon avis au
devant des pires difficultés et
effectivement un médecin il a vraiment
besoin passer tout son temps mais
exclusivement à son patient ce qui est
pas tout à fait le cas du pharmacien où
on passe avec Lab avec les
négociation on est
structurétis vrai sujet est là pour
quand Mme une double peine qui leur est
infligée la première effectivement c'est
l'alourdissement de le système
administratif qui va aller manger et la
deuxième c'est le risque d'abus et ils
en parlent très clairement et puis après
même le glissementis des mutuels qui
vont prendre un petit peu la main sur le
sur la sécurité sociale et qui qui on le
sait très bien vont finir par dire à
leur à leurs assurés bah allez donc vous
faire soigner chez chez Paul parce que
on a un accord avec lui c'est un peu
moins cher et cetera donc c'est ça le
fondamentalement au-delà du boulot du
médecin il y a aussi le libre choix qui
est quand même assez intéressant en
France de P faire soigner à peu près
puis c'est un vrai libéral le médecin
est un vrai libéral on n pas envie de
savoir combien il fait de clients par
jour on a bien savoir combien
effectivement euh enfin voilà il y a un
vrai c'est un vrai libéral il veent être
libre je CIS c'est non mais je crois que
mapha et JeanCharles ont donné vraiment
bien les deux éclairages sur les deux
problématiques de de cette question là
et moi je enfin en tant que
professionnel c'est vrai qu'en tant que
patient ce serait super d'y aller je
mets ma carte je paye pas et je m'en
vais mais en tant que professionnel
c'est vrai que les pharmaciens sont
structurés différemment ils ont des
salariés voilà c'est c'est autre chose
ils sont informatisés ils sont pe
importe mais il y a des les médecins ils
sont tout seuls ils ont pas de forcément
de secrét sauf s'ils ont dans des
cabinets médicaux mais c'est pas du tout
les mêmes structures et je vois pas
comment ils peuvent arriver i au-delà de
leur travail à gérer ce problème là et
et attends je termine juste et
effectivement la mainmise des assuran
des compagnies d'assurance qui fait M
mise un peu partout donc un danger
danger verni un danger mais en même
temps je pense que lorsqu'on a on a les
moyens en fait d'avancer ses frais ça
pose pas vraiment de problème parce
qu'au final le remboursement est le même
la la séu rembourse 3 jours après puis
la mutuelle suivant les mutuel va
rembourser une à de semaines derrière
maintenant pour quelqu'un je prends mon
cas en tant qu'étudiante ou les gens qui
ont moins les moyens pour eux ça fait
vraiment la différence par parce que
lorsqu'il faut aller chez le dermato
c'est 55 € chez l'oftalmo c'est 55 € 55
€ dans un budget qui peut être restreint
voire minime euh B on peut se dire non
ben je vais pas y aller alors que
j'aurais besoin d'y aller donc au final
des dérives et des abus malheureusement
il y en a toujours certainement que là
les gens vont exploiter les failles si
faill il y aura dans le système
maintenant je pense qu'il y en aura pas
forcément plus que ça et que ça fait
partie mais l'aide
médicale l'aide médicale elle existe
quand même pour les plus défavorisés
ouais payer le payer ce qui dépasse
c'est vrai que me dit Sephora c'est un
frein pour ceux qui les ont pas tout
simplement c'est un frein c'est qu'on
sait qu'on va se faire rembourser ça
demeure un frein je vais les sortir mais
peut-être qu'ils vont pas me les rendre
c'est un et par contre par contre par
contre la solution quand même il faut
parler de solution parce qu'après tout
en France on a aussi besoin de faire des
économies parce que ça part d'un bon
sentiment quand même il y a pas le
sentiment de vouloir casser une
profession pour la casser il y a le
sentiment que on peut faire des
économies mais là c'est en amont
c'est-àdire au niveau de la sécurité
sociale parce que ça va permettre des
économies éelle cette fois-ci à la C il
y a une solution c'est que les médecins
viennent à se structurer de la même
façon c'est qu' des pôles médicaux avec
une personne dédiée qui pourrait gérer
ça donc la solution elle existe c'est
simplement
que tuas
réinvente le système de structuration
qui permet des économies
d'chelleum qui estme enur du TI payant
c'est que beaucoup oup de gens qui n'ont
pas les moyens vont aux urgences des
hôpitaux plus pour ne pas payer que ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher que d'aller
voir médecin
généraliste pour
répond pour
G le RIM dans
préé les plus pauvres peuvent se faire
soigner en France on parle de pvreté
parle G qui pas tout à fait beaucoup de
médecins qui acceptent d'encaisser
l'échec très arrangeantme après que vous
soyez remboursé après qu'on soit
remboursé allez on passe à un autre
sujet la peut-être la polémique sur
Christian tobira qui est bah c'est une
polémique qui rebondit presque chaque
semaine enfin il y a toujours une phrase
alors une phrase dont on sait pas si
elle relève du racisme si elle relève de
la politique là il y a une une élu
d'Île-de-France qui a dit bah elle a qu'
retourner à Cayenne voilà mais c'était
d'abord on sait même pas si on a le
droit de de de de de faire un débat
là-dessus parce que de toute façon on a
le droit de rien dire sur tobira donc il
faut peser chaque mot
jà c'est que dès qu'on dès qu'on attaque
cette dame immédiatement on est traité
de tous les
noms la façon don on l'attaque il a
toujours parfois il y a parfois un
rel vous qui êes tous raciste parce que
c'est donc raciste de venir de CEN que
si moi je vous dis retourner à peau
c'est pas raciste Patrice retourner à pe
voilàs bien mais retourner à Cayen c'est
raciste donc il effectivement une partie
de la France il y a une partie de la
France dont on doit avoir honte c'estàd
Cayenne visiblement si on écoute madame
tbira donc Cayen c'est honteux et po
c'est
génial ça c'est la première chose de
deuxièmement l'argument peut-être idiot
de toute façon je trouve ça ridicule de
conseiller à quelqu'un de retourner où
que ce soit donc l'argument est IDI mais
il est tout SAU raciste il est
simplement géographique et stupide ça
c'est c'est une chose deuxièmement
l'autre l'autre AFF faaire c'est quand
quelqu'un a osé
dire Christian tobira est un tracte
ambulant pour le FN bon d'abord à titre
personnel je pense je pense qu'il a
totalement raison mais il paraît que le
truc raciste c'est ambulant parce que
ambulant non il y a des journalistes et
ARL Chabot notamment qui qui je crois a
dit oui parce que dans s'il avait pas
dit ambulant ce serait rien mais
ambulant ça fait appel à un passé où
effectivement les Noirs pouvaient se
promener dans des conditions pas grav
alors si on en est
là est du est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes sûr quand même que derrière les
attaques contre chrtian toira il y a pas
quelque chose comme ça un reland qui
fait penser à à sa couleur de peau comme
est noir on on peut pas la critiquer
donc si on est noir on peut rien
dire l'allusion au bagne ça veut dire
les tout tout elle vient C elle étal à C
a dit Cayenne où il y avait le bagne et
alors elle a brûlé le drapeau français à
Cayenne ça la dérangeait pas à ce
momentlà l'allusion c'était de dire vos
amis les bagnards vu que vous
défendez en
contact minère de la justice c'est votre
Ministre V regard c'était des blancs les
bagnards non non enfin moi je pense que
quand on peut critiquer des gens quel
que soit leur provenance le couleur et
Cera mais faut les critiquer de manière
intelligente sur de la politique et je
trouve ça moi totalement
idiot et crétant de dire dire qu'elle
retourne à Cayenne où il y a le bagne
parce que le mot bagne était dans la
phrase donc je trouve ça complètement
ridicule comme tu dis c'est ID dire à
quelqu'un retourne même à pe je trouve
ça ridicule aussi mais voilà je trouve
ça très court je trouve ça volon voilà
je trouve
ça volontairementoc c'est volontairement
provocateur donc derrière qu'est-ce
qu'il y a parce que c'est quand même il
y a de la provocation et derrière de
volonté probablement de déstabilisation
politique et énerver tout le monde
d'ailleurs ça marche mais moi je trouve
ça ridicule des gens faut les critiquer
sur des actes sur de la politique et pas
sur leur personne en tant
que c'était extrêmement c'était
extrêmement cétait une critique
véritablement politique que de dire que
c'est un tract ambulant pour le Front
national c'est c'est politique de dire
que la polique pas fait un tra est-ce
qu'on pas fait un tract contre le Front
national parce que après tout est minist
de la justice je vois pas enfin quand on
lu quand on lui l'accuse de de de
dépeupler les prisons en fait il y a une
surpopulation prise donc c'est quand
même d'abord c'est pas vrai et ensuite
c'est nécessaire enfin je dire on en
fait quand même un symbole comme ça de
de non cristallise tous les problèmes
sur de choses le fait qu'elle soit noire
à mon avis n'est pas forcément innocent
làant n pas forcément de choses non
si dire d'abord d'abord il y a
l'accumulation sur te bien je crois
qu'on on peut le dire
att fin une phrase tuux merci parce que
il y a des gens qui nous regardent qui
pourrait penser que je suis centuré
parce que oui
voilà
voilà donc premièrement c'est quand même
très accumulé sur sa personne je crois
qu'on peut au moins être d'accord
là-dessus et que effectivement comme le
dit
Florence c'est le cumul à un moment
donné c'est pas le cumul desmandant en
ce qui la concerne donc la la première
desmandales bien donc donc Florence a
raison et non non mais vraiment ça c'est
la première chose mais par contrei je
plaide et je l'ai déjà je crois l'avoir
dit la dernière émission je plaide pour
cette dédramatisation des mots et moi je
pense que c'est l'inverse que finalement
tous ces gens qui qui qui ont ce ce type
de de sali
finalement on est tous conscient que
c'est complètement imbécile je crois
même que il y a des mots qui ont été
employés à l'endroit de d'un Premier
ministre on va dire crétin et donc je
pense que c'est on s' on on s'en rend
bien compte je pense que c'est plutôt au
ministre au pluriel face à des attaques
à dominum de cette nature en tous les
cas de rester beaucoup plus allez on va
dire plus plus politiquement correct
plus ouais plus plus costaud et de
passer à autre chose parce que je le
disais la dernière fois je répète j'ai
un film que j'adore l'enny de l'ENIB
brus où cette idée de dédramatiser les
mots moi c'est ce que j'apprends au
gamin sur les terrains à un moment donné
dans sur les terrains il y a des
insultes absolument terrifiantes qui
génèent tellement de violence qu'on
apprend entre guillemets les crash tests
je trouve qu'à ce niveau euh
gouvernemental on devrait avoir un peu
plus d'apaisement face à ce type de
critique et laisser la critique là où
elle est elle mais c'est Florence qui a
raison raciste c'est déplacé c'est
stupide c'est cumulatif c'est n'importe
quoi final le
ministre député mais je veux dire
employé des termes d'un
mépris Scand c'est pas la seule à être
méprisante il y a d'autres mépris il y a
d'autres mépris d'ailleurs mais il y a
pas de racisme aussi ensuite c'est ce
qui fait CIS le problème avec Toiras
c'est ça c'est que c'est depuis le début
madame tobira s'il vous plaît madame
tobira une sorte de de de bouqu
émissaire oui et non mais en tout cas
une tête de turque par rapport à ça le
fait qu'elle soit noir c'est peut-être
le point faible du gouvernement aussi he
le fait qu'elle soit noire n'est pas
n'est pas innocent on lui reproche une
certaine forme de laxisme c'est surtout
ce qui lui est ce qui lui est reproché a
tort ou a raison parce qu'il paraît pas
tant que ça euh bon elle fait de son
mieux mais oui c'est vrai à une époque
je crois qu'elle s'était fait traiter de
singe aussi bon c'est là les gens ont
été condamnés il y a un journal qui a
été condamné qu voilà quand il des
vraies attaquesac il y a un terrain
sensible autour de tobira par rapport à
sa couleur de
PE qui va être intéressant c'est après
les départementales s'il y a un
remanement est-ce qu'elle va rester ou
pas est-ce qu'elle va rester ou pas
c'est un symbole en même temps c'est
compliqué de la êtile alors puisque des
rares femmes en politique qu'on appelle
par son nom tobira sgolen on les appelle
toutes par leur prénom d'ailleurs ce qui
est à peu près tout aussi sexiste que
raciste la droite devrait devrait bien
l'aimer puisque c'est grâce à elle que
shirac était élu quand même en 2002
puisquelle s'était prés ent contre josp
et enlevé 2 %
des après avoir brûlé le drapeau
français sétait allié à tapi bah oui
enfin je elle avait pas 15 ans quand
elle a brûlé le drapau français donc
c'est pas rien quand même pour un
ministre et son mari fut longtemp leader
des indépendant voilà donc Mar on n pas
responsable non plus
Opin qui sont à peu près rattrapés
depuis on en a plein des exemples
puisque vous parliez des des des
élections départementales oui il y a il
y a on peut changer d'avis aussi
on peut tout à fa changer mais ce on
peut émettre un petit regret en disant
c'était une boulette c'était mais j'ai
jamais entendu et je vous défie de
trouver une parole de Christian tobira
de Madame Christian tobira garde des sa
de dire c'est effectivement par ce que
j'ai fait de mieux dans la vie que de
brûler le drapeau français je ne l'ai
jamais entendu dire ah ben moi je lui
pose je lui pose et qu'elle le dise
alors madame
Christian vous
regz faire de V regres ou
pas est-ce que vous parliez des
départemental donc on sait que
l'abstention sera encore le grand
vainqueur de C il faut all voter il faut
all il faut voter
mais les les sondages montrent que les
gens ne connaissent pas le leurs élus
départementaux alors on va faire un
petit test si si vous voulez bien je
vais vous demander par exemple est-ce
que vous connaissez qui est le président
du conseil général des ivelines bien sûr
oui nous le savons on va pas il est
parti il est revenu Bédier Pierre
Bédier oh 67 ans ouai
57 ça ou et quel quel quel mouvement
quel parti UMP UMP voilà alors il est en
fonction en eff faet depuis le le le 4
novembre 2014 est-ce que vous connaissez
le président du conseil départemental de
la sainte
saintenis euh Barcelone non c'était
Barcelone
avant 7 minut qu'on est censé connaître
parce que c'est quand même la région
parisienne je pas vous interroger
sur le 9
93 Stéphan
trous est-ce que vous connaissez le
président du conseil général de
leson qui est connu qui est
un par socialiste 43
ans
les SC de vjan
bravo un point pour
Florence Patrick de V qui a quel âge 57
ans
70 ah
la droite ça conserve un avocat la scène
saint donc c'est Stéphane Troussel qui a
remplacé Claude Bartelone la scène est
Marne c'est
c'est déjà reposition ces régions là et
Patrice vous connaissez le président de
la région de PO alors bien sûr François
Baayou bon va Vincent hblé c'est Vincent
oui c'est le maire de Po qui est Vincent
Eblé Vincent Eblé 57 ans du Parti
socialiste absolument ah le président ça
c'est inéressant le président du du
Conseil Général du
valdemarne qui est parent avec le
président de TV Phil
78 ah mais oui d'c c'est quand même
incroyable enfin incroyable c'est pas
incroyable c'est son frère Vernier
Verdier Favier Christian Favier mais qui
est du Parti communiste c'est dire
qu'ils sont frères mais pas du tout du
même et alors pour qu'on s'intéresse un
peu à tout à Cayen alors qui est-ce
Cayen c'est je crois que c'est je sais
plus qui c'est mais non non c'est un ce
manque de
connaissance inro
tout le monde s'en
fout est-ce que Paris il y a un
président de conseil général ou pas non
parce que c'est Paris ve pas à Paris on
v pas donc c'est que c'est le conseil
municipal qui
estén évidemment je disais l'abstention
aussi le le vote du Front national je
propose de regarder un petit micro
trottoir on demande aux gens si est-ce
qu'ils vont voter ou non pour le Front
national aux élections départementales
ah non pas le frond national surtout pas
le frond national non question de
conviction voilà tout simplement non
j'ai jamais été Front national je trouve
que il y a quelque chose de qui me
dérange qui est violent qui je suis plus
quelqu'un qui qui vait moduler les chose
et le Front National est trop extrémiste
pour moi oui oui oui sans problème pour
quelle raison parce que aujourd'hui
l'offre politique correspond plus du
tout à ce que on peut espérer que ça
soit à droite ou à gauche donc pourquoi
pas changer et voir un petit peu ce que
eux sont capables de faire ah non pas du
tout parce que nous sommes engagés dans
dans un autre parti pourquoi pas pour
quelle raison parce que c'est un parti
comme un autre non parce que je ne pas
partage pas leur point de vue alors
voilà ça c'était pour le Front national
ça sera probablement les deux grand
vainqueurs le Front national
l'abstention et il y a une proposition
qui vient des vers d'ailleurs pourquoi
ne pas rendre le vote obligatoire comme
ça se passe en bel au Luxembourg dans un
certain nombre de pays qui pour qui est
contre Véronique pour deux raisons
d'abord ça rendrait les politiques un
peu plus sensibles aux attentes et au
besoins de leurs électeurs puisque tout
le monde voterait un exemple par exemple
une V tout le monde voterait pas non non
c'est obligatoire vous avez une sanction
si vous si vous votez pas la sanction
est absolument inapplicableon mais quand
même mais c'est un princip cassez pas
mon truc donc voilà imaginons une ville
des jeunes réclament je dis au hasard un
skate park le maire sait très bien que
les jeunes ne vote pas il s'en fiche il
va faire plaisir au vieux qui eu il qui
eux votent c'est simpliste mais c'est
vrai Bou voilà chacun vous des trucs et
Deo ben je sais plus non c'est bien non
j'avais deux
raisons non je dir après je trouve ça
ridicule d'obliger les gens à voter si
si les gens n'ont pas envie de voter
qu'ils aillent pas voter c'est qu' c'est
qu' sont pas c'est qu'il sont pas
intéressés moi la seule chose c'est que
quand on ne vote pas on devrait pas
avoir le droit moral de raller c'estàd
que si on va pas voter on s'intéresse
non mais c'est compliqué à contrôler non
non c'est pour ça que je parle de une AM
mais bien sûr c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça non mais j'ai toujours voté et je
vais toujours voter mais je comprends
très bien qu' on puisse ne pas y aller
et tant pis je veux dire c'est pas on n
pas à forcer les gens à prendre des des
décisions qui les concern pas ensuite
tous les gens qui votent on sa trs la
démocratie c'est merveilleux en c'est
quand même pas ce qu'on a trouvé de
moins pire mais donc moins il y a de
gens qui peuvent émettre un avis idiot
quelque fois mais on porte donc dit je
crois que ça ne change pas
rés
Jech Jean-Charles a un avis sur la
société quand même assez
défétistes pardon
pardon Florence oui non mais moi je suis
pour le vote obligatoire c'est je pense
c'est un devoir on s'est battu pour
avoir le droit de vote il y a encore des
des des peuples qui se battent pour
avoir le droit de
voteant on s battu pour une liberté
c'est marrant de rend de cette liberté
obligatoire ENF je sa pas c'est bien
d'avoir liberté obligatoire moi je
trouve je P bizarre liberté
obligatoire un devoir c'est un devoir
vis-à-is de la nation c'est un devoir
personnel non c'est pas un devoir devo
CIV si on est intelligent on va voter si
on est va
pas aussi clair que
ça Mo simple que
ça en ce qui me concerne je trouve ça
choquant de ne pas aller voter en
revanche je préfère la liberté que les
gens puissent avoir de voter ou de ne
pas voter parce que ça fait partie de
cette liberté l'acquisition du droit de
vote c'est important mais c'est aussi
l'acquisition de toutes les libertés au
moins celle-là de voter ou ne pas voter
et puis surtout il y a un autre élément
important c'est qu'en fait on a un vote
permanent ça s'appelle le sondage et moi
j'ai pour avoir fait un peu de
statistique à partir du moment où vous
voulez rendre quasiment réelle une une
théorie vous faites un sondage et il y a
un nombre à peu près à peu près compris
de tous en tous les cas au niveau des
statistiques c'est que quand vous avez
1000 ou 1500 personnes qui sont
interrogées sur le plan national sur le
plan local en l'occurrence le
microotottoire qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
je suis sûr qu'il y a un tiers qui dit
qu'il voulait voter pour le Front
national or statistiquement dans les
sondages il y a un ti mic ça sauf que le
nombre n'est pas suffisant pour qu'on
puisse réellement tirer quelque chose de
ce reportage j'entends sur le plan
statistique c'est donc le fait de rendre
obligatoire allez imaginons queil y ait
28 millions de personnes qui se
déplacent d'abord on rendre obligatoire
lesquels le National le local le
régional le prud de mal lesquels on
rendra obligatoire et comment les
contrôle alors tous ok on F peut-être on
ferut-êre une recette parce que il y a
beaucoup de poons à prendre avec
l'abstention et donc la donc donc ce que
je voulais dire c'est que en fait en
fait il suffit de très peu de monde pour
avoir une
représentativité et donc aujourd'hui
quel que soit le le pourcentage
d'abstention qu'on a on a de toute façon
proportionnellement la représentation
change rien la représentation ce projet
do en fait c'est un cheval de TR parce
qu'on peut être sûr que si ça va un peu
plus loin on va c'est une possibilité de
remettre le droit de vote des étrangers
sur le tapis c'est une évidence c'est sû
par qu'on va direce qu'on obligé de
voter pour moi je suis pour je pense que
le droit de vote doit être obligatoire
on s'est battu au 19e au 20e pour y
avoir droit aujourd'hui il y a une forme
de de conscience qui s'effacee un peu
justement on en a plus suffisamment
conscience et les gens n'y vont plus il
faut se mobiliser il faut retourner
voter je pense que c'est important et en
fait à force justement d'obliger les
gens qui pour certains en grande partie
iront vootter même s'il y aura toujours
deux trois absentionnistes il faudrait
aussi que le vote blanc soit pris en
compte ça c'est une évidence si on rend
le vote obligatoire faut que le vote
blanc soit pris en compte il est pr est
pr en fait c'est fait
d'accord et par contre et par contre je
pense qu'à force justement ça créit une
forme de sensibilisation démocratique et
peut-être que les gens se sentiraient
par cette façonl à long terme plus
concernés se mobiliseraient davantage
c'est notre pays c'est notre
gouvernement c'est grâce à nous ou à
cause de
nous écoutez je d'accord avec toi ne pas
voter
c'est se soustraire de la collectivité
et comme le disait Jean-Charles à partir
moment on vote pas on n'a pas le droit
d'aller raller donc je pense qu'il faut
inciter les gens à aller voter le rendre
obligatoire par la loi est probablement
une solution il y en a peut-être
d'autres pour ce qui me concerne je
préconise et je me Bagard chaque jour de
ma vie pour faire en sorte que tout
individu soit inscrit dans la
collectivité et par conséquent je pense
que le vote contribue à cela plein de
gens sont morts pour défendre la
démocratie une des expressions
démocratie c'est le droit de vote je
pense qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui dire
on s'en fout gardons notre liberté et on
va pas voter non il y a au moins une
chose sur laquelle il faut contribuer au
collectif c'est dans le cadre de
l'esprit civique et ça se traduit par
l'obligation d'aller voter donc moi je
suis pour l'obligation d'aller voter
Véronique en 30 secondes vous un coup de
gueule c'est pas une minute c'est
secondes alors je voulais profiter du 8
mars qui n'est pas loin et de la Semaine
de la langue française qui arrive pour
vous dire que moi j'en a r bol d'un truc
j'en a r bol d'entendre des ados des
jeunes adultes parler de la sorte à
savoir ta mère ta mère ta mère la
ta mère en short retourne chez ta mère
mal la vérité sur la tête de ma mère
tout ça et je trouve ça très choquant et
très fatiguant parce que moi j'ai trois
enfants j'ai été appelé des milliards de
fois par mes enfants maman maman j'ai
mal au ventre maman j'ai envie de
pleurer maman j'ai j'ai peur maman j'ai
froid on répond et après moi j'entends
c'est ta mère tout le temps partout et
je bon concerné je suis pas concerné non
mais je veux dire on arrête je vrais que
les mères le disent à leurs enfants on
arrête de parler de ta mère à un âge on
appelle c'était un coup de gueule merci
beaucoup Véronique merci beaucoup à tous
et on se retrouve très vite pour un
nouveau PAF
bravo